hallo damals luca war der liebe freuen
wenn ich war heute junge challenge
ein
bild für die götter
und ausgestattet wie talent das hier ist
das erste yoga teil was wir versuchen
nachzustellen
ich weiß nicht womit ich anfangen soll
ich glaube ist die hände ich glaube erst
mal hinsetzen wir machen das jetzt so
weit ich also dass bald was fordert ist
das hebt sie hoch die das macht sie mit
dem ellbogen hier irgendwie
verrückt mein bauch zusammen ich sehe
von 30 dollar machen wir halt mit kurzer
machen wir das spiel schon vergleichen
sieg im 32
das hat funktioniert zwei challenge ist
das hier ein problem
werden also wir müssen uns hinstellen
und das bein was gerade ist ist bei mir
das rechte und bei dir auch das rechte
beiden das rechte dann den linken fuß
hochziehen
ich kann mich
hast du du kommst doch ein anderer was
ich muss dich hier festhalten so warum
stimmt ja wohl
und das hier ist die nächste yoga
position machen müssen
zusammen untergehen darf dann aus
anfängt ist schon mal heiraten
wir müssen sowieso zusammen durch beide
arme durch
also ich muss sagen so machen du musst
dann hier schon durch weißt du denn ich
mache so du gehst durch weite wie kommst
du you have längere zeit trocken
das ist so anstrengend dass hier ist die
nächste position die wir umsetzen werden
ich bin die unteren person der
kommandobrücke nach vorne sowie als
liegestütz mal ein bisschen der quelle
genau so und ich muss mich jetzt auf
dich drauf legen musste wurde fließen
[Gelächter]
das hier ist die nächste yoga position
geht in eine ähnliche richtung wie das
erste was wir gemacht haben aber ein
bisschen leichter also ich da einfach so
dass man
muss nur den mut machen oder so ja drei
nein
das hier ist die nächste yoga position
dass auch die sie bis hin zur
abwechslung einfach schneidersitz
so lustig
das ist die nächste position die dran
glauben muss schon mal kann man besser
ist also dass wir die brücke aber war
der brand bei der die füße von der matte
runter vielleicht sogar ja genau ich
sage jetzt schon wer nur kurz in meine
fresse ich würde ja gar nicht das macht
was
war das denn du ja das ist die nächste
position müssen wegen dieser herz machen
also beide die andere richtung von uns
rein so
roßkopf selbst wenn beide ausstrecken
und oberschenkeln zu sich genommen
jetzt müssen wir jetzt hier mit links
geben
das ist die nächste yoga position und
[Musik]
niemals so stecken
beide füße nebeneinander
hier stelle ich die neue mich annehmen
die haben die fußballer machen nein doch
was ist eigentlich ein
vorlauter oder zu haben
ich sage euch ganz ehrlich johann schild
mit leuten die ihr nicht mitmacht es
niemals mag sich nun auch für mich
hast du hast bestimmt nicht denkt wie
gebrochen ist doch das hier ist die
nächste position sebastian kausch durch
einen kopfstoss aber du bist doch viel
kleiner und musste hamilton kosten
sitzen krupp stunden kein nein mein
gehirn dass es mir wichtig wo soll ich
denn funktioniert neben muss ja hier
stehen und mich halten doch
erwarte aber wenn ich weiß nicht wie ein
läufer
und das ist meine wandern also
das hier ist die nächste position wir
müssen uns beide schneidersitz vor
- seinen rechten arm hierhin machen zum
heim linken
und wenn ich hier 13
das geht eigentlich sehr
dass die mäßigung seiner positionen es
gar nicht so heißt es gleich im ersten
rennen konnte
ich
würde sagen wir fahren rennen eben doch
einfach mal zu mir kommst
und jetzt halt wir beide unsere arme
fest und jetzt machen wir unsere beiden
[Musik]
darsteller
das ist die opposition nicht ob googles
die person sein die lina herab ich
wollte da vorne dann muss ich nur so man
muss sich nicht anmelden
auch das hier ist die nächste yoga
position in dieser zeit schon tausendmal
du dich einsatz ich weiß es nicht ich
hab mir du musst deine beiden profis oft
eine kinderfüße
und das ist yoga position
die orangen spitze welten als zumal was
sie ist die allerletzte yoga challenge
freute da stehen wir beiden mit unseren
beiden beinen hier nebeneinander
genau mit diesen wiesen berühren wir uns
nehmen mussten und müssen uns hinten
umarmt bevor die müssen wir die hände
aneinander machen
so alle stellen heutigen video werden
die jugend ulrich schwarz überwachung
auf jeden fall noch mal wieder lassen
daumen runter video damals nicht
gefallen hat ich hätte ich mehr weiter
holt mich hier raus polizei krankenwagen
justiz holt mich hier raus geld noch
da